you're awesome man I'm thrilled that
you're part of this freaking thing and
and this is just the beginning so uh
beginning all these strange allies just
pop out of the woodwork you know what I
mean if you would have told me that we'd
be sitting here a month ago I'd be like
what the hell are you talking about and
yeah easy and yet here we are yeah and
it's a beautiful thing like I love like
I'm so just about positivity and
spreading that and I'm so not political
so it's like kind of cool to just have a
platform that's just like doesn't give a
[ __ ] if you're political or anything no
I could be the most liberal left-wing
guy yeah on on Rumble and I will be
allowed of course my [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying like that's the beauty of it
that's that's why I [ __ ] we got good
but that's why I love it because Chris
because Chris could give me the deal
that he gave me and then I could be like
yo buddy I'm [ __ ] the biggest biting
supporter in the world I'm gonna rep the
[ __ ] he wouldn't give a [ __ ] it's not
it's not about politics no it's about
content entertainment like YouTube is
content entertainment it it's for the
people it's like why do we need to get
in this adult politic [ __ ] like no one
gives a [ __ ] like I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah my fans don't give a [ __ ] about I I
mean I I'm speaking for my fans but I
truly believe that that my fans that are
16 to 30 years old don't truly give a
[ __ ] that much about politics like that
and they're basing it it sucks that you
have to base the entire world and every
tech company around politics you know
not anymore man not anymore but I just
hope I just hope that it stays that
Rumble stays the thing because you know
it's a [ __ ] War out there yeah you
know like
Rumble could get like I don't know I
don't know we can't get deleted we got
no it's a war so like for you guys to
even go public and do all this it's like
you guys are like kind of winning that
war it's like it's it's crazy the
Insurgency is here yeah so I hope thank
you so much glad to be partnered with
you I'm glad to be on it I'm glad to
make videos all I like to do is get
yourself some champagne man I'm gonna
get Champagne by if you guys watching
I'm gonna make videos
in like two to three two to four weeks
from now and it's like I love making
videos I love changing lives uh I'm
gonna say this right now no disrespect
to YouTube but [ __ ] you YouTube no
disrespect but like you banned me for a
website that you allow on your platform
like if you're gonna ban me for a
website on my second Channel I guess
100K like at least and not allow it on
your platform you [ __ ] communist
[ __ ] like like Ben me because I did
something wrong don't ban me for a
fucking.com on a what on my second
Channel like it's 100K views for a
website that you [ __ ] allow you allow
this website we'll just say it all right
you're gonna be all right I'm gonna be
all right but it just pisses me off and
you know new opportunity and YouTube you
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up
you you do I have real fans YouTube you
don't have real fans you're a bunch of
commie bastards [ __ ] you I'm so sorry is
this live
but you know what the beauty about
Rumble is
you can make mistakes I like that you're
getting closer to the camera it's like
really you know oh but the thing is you
guys
banned me for a website that you allow
on your platform like let's like let's
let that sink in
I hear you man they've been they've been
hitting me for a long time but imagine
like all right we'll just keeping
Rolexes out we'll save for that is okay
hey my name's YouTube hey buddy how you
doing
um you can um there's this website
called steak.com you can play it on on
our platform you can show you Planet you
can say hey verbally hey I'm on stake
it's the best gambling website ever you
can say that but if you have that.com
that is [ __ ] bad yeah you are
promoting a bad website yeah you are a
scum bag piece of [ __ ] if they see
that.com you know you're gonna get
people to gamble but you know things you
gamble on that website tell them that
you're playing on that website say where
you're playing show them that you're
playing show but if you show that.com
because all these guys are idiots they
don't know how to they don't know how to
get to that website unless there's
the.com they just think steak like
they're gonna think like rib eye yeah
but that's that's what I'm dealing with
makes no sense
so I love you guys I'm probably getting
calls from from my business partner
saying hey you need to chill the [ __ ]
out
but
um I love you guys so much big videos
coming Steve will do videos going live
um I love you guys thank you for so much
for having me thanks brother thank you
so much all right uh
I can't tell there's a screen okay this
is the camera okay I love you guys
Steve will do a sign out once a week
Steve
that was definitely the most colorful uh
thing that has ever happened at NASDAQ
and I think indicative of uh what's
going on over here at Rumble the whole
point is that nobody if you're a Dark
comic because you're giving Rolexes to
Trump if you're a lefty like Glenn
Greenwald or Tulsi gabbard or you're a
crazy right-winger like Dave Rubin or
Dan bong you know you are welcome to be
on this platform free speech is going
public